bernard and i both grew up with the  monkey king story my father used to read  to me bedtime stories about you know  monkey king and it's really a  foundational story  in chinese culture monkey king is a  little bit more mischievous and more  defiant and rebellious  he is a rule breaker and as the story  progresses he learns to break rules for  the right reasons  batman and and robin and  their mythos is going to be pretty tied  in a lot of it is like you know gotham  city high what does that look like the  fight scene is great to draw it leaves  on a tremendous cliffhanger it has to be  a very dc specific version of the monkey  legend  a lot of us who are asian american we  grow up trying to integrate these  eastern and western influences and this  project is exactly that hopefully  somebody's going to be reading this to  their kid at night and be able to  carry that forward because it's just  magical  [Music]  you